trump belongs in prison more than he  belongs on presidential polls the idea  that trump might even have a shot at the  republican nomination  is  extraordinarily disturbing  and embarrassing for the country  this is a guy who should never be  running again for anything he shouldn't  be allowed to run again based on the  things that he that he's done  and instead he's  in it in a hypothetical matchup for the  presidency and it says way more about  the voters than it does about donald  trump himself and so as i always say  it's time to start getting your friends  your family and your community  um aware of the fact that they must vote  and what better way to warm up to voting  in 2024 than voting in 2022